kirikan Provinz Hatay hier arbeiten die
deutschen Technisches Hilfswerk und die
Suchtrupps der Hilfsorganisation Isa in
diesem Haus haben sie Stimmen gehört von
weit unten Tag 4 die Zeit drängt sie
beide Karaman weiß das und sie bankt um
das Leben ihrer Schwester und deren
Familie sie sind noch irgendwo da drin
seit gestern sind viele Rettungskräfte
hier und sie arbeiten auf Hochtouren das
ist gut seit vier Tagen haben wir nicht
geschlafen wir haben auf Hilfe gewartet
zwei Tage lang kam niemand aber jetzt
scheint alles ganz gut zu laufen ich
hoffe dass sie meinen Schwager meinen
Neffen meine Nichte und meine Schwester
lebend rausholen werden
die Helfer versuchen so beide Karaman
aufzumuntern ja sie haben Kontakt zur
Schwester können mit ihr reden können
ihr Hoffnung geben und sie haben sogar
einen Weg gefunden sie in dem Hohlraum
unter dem Schutz zu versorgen
wir haben ihr Wasser geben können über
eine schlauchkonstruktion mit einer
Wasserflasche sehr kompliziert aber die
Frau hat Wasser bekommen das hat ihre
Lebensgeister natürlich noch mal geweckt
und wir versuchen Sie unten in der
trümmerschicht natürlich zu motivieren
dass sie halt auch ne weiß wir kommen
sie hört natürlich auch dass wir
arbeiten aber diese soziale
Unterstützung ist natürlich extrem
wichtig ne das ist dunkel da unten ähm
das ist nicht schön die Angehörigen
warten und hoffen dass es Ihre Leute
schaffen auch nach vier langen Tagen und
Nächten noch die meisten aber die sie
jetzt aus den Trümmern Bergen haben es
nicht geschafft in den Straßen von
hathai liegen die Leichen die Hoffnung
noch Überlebende zu finden schwindet mit
jeder Stunde
zumindest kommen jetzt Hilfsgüter für
die Lebenden in Hatay an Wasser
Nahrungsmittel Kleidung endlich nach
drei Tagen in der Kälte ohne Dach über
dem Kopf das lange Warten aber hat viele
hier zermünde
alles ist kaputt überall sind unsere
Häuser sind zerstört
sie wollen helfen in Istanbul weit
entfernt vom Erdbebengebiet sammeln
freiwillige Spenden packen Hilfspakete
für die Menschen in Hatay und den
anderen zerstörten Städten
organisiert vom Stadtbezirk kommen jeden
Tag hunderte um anzupacken so wie Fatma
Gül
in diesen Säcken sind Bettdecken und
Kissen wir verpacken sie einzelnen
Plastiktüten bevor sie in die Kartons
kommen damit sie nicht nass werden sonst
kann man sie nicht mehr gebrauchen
auch Fatma Gül hat Freunde und Verwandte
im Erdbebengebiet zum Glück geht es
ihnen gut sagte
ich konnte nicht alle erreichen aber ich
habe von ihnen positive Nachrichten
bekommen wir hoffen dass das alles bald
ein Ende hat und dass unser Volk nicht
mehr leiden muss
es ist eine riesige Welle der
Solidarität 25 Sattelschlepper sagen sie
uns hätten sie allein am Vortag
losgeschickt und die seien auch
angekommen bei den Menschen im
Erdbebengebiet es hat Tage gedauert doch
jetzt rollt die Hilfe in der Türkei auf
der Autobahn Richtung syrische Grenze
aber ging tagelang nichts der Übergang
sei beschädigt hieß es von türkischer
Seite auch in Syrien wütete das Beben
doch weil Bürgerkrieg herrscht weil sich
Regierung und Rebellen bekämpfen waren
die Menschen hier auf sich gestellt wie
im Ort janderes Ibrahim kalining Karin
verlor sieben Familienmitglieder sie
alle liegen noch unter den Trümmern
seines Hauses
nach dem Erdbeben haben wir gehofft dass
andere Länder kommen würden um uns zu
helfen aber es kamen nur die guten
Menschen aus unserer Nachbarschaft nach
dem Beben warten wir den Besitzer des
Krans nach unseren Angehörigen zu suchen
er sagte er habe anderswo zu tun und
habe auch keinen Treibstoff niemand
hilft uns
zunächst sind es nur mit dem Assad
Regime befreundete Staaten wie Pakistan
Russland Iran die Hilfe schicken mehr
symbolisch wohl
in die von Rebellen kontrollierten
Gebiete im Norden kommt erst mal niemand
nach Tagen politischer Verhandlungen
auch mit der Türkei wird die für die
syrischen Erdbeben Opfer tödliche
Blockade gelockert
der Grenzübergang ins Erdbebengebiet im
Norden wird geöffnet ein erster
un-konvoi kann ins Land ein Tropfen auf
den heißen Stein vier Tage nach dem
Beben
da tobt auf der anderen Seite der Grenze
in der Türkei schon längst der Wahlkampf
auch in Zeiten der Krise Präsident Recep
Tayyip Erdogan besucht Erdbebenopfer in
Hatay viel zu lange habe es gedauert bis
Hilfe kam beschweren sich viele der
Präsident gibt zu man sei vom Ausmaß der
Katastrophe überrascht worden dann aber
maßregelt er seine Kritiker
es ist die Zeit der Solidarität ich kann
es nicht ertragen wenn jemand in einer
solchen Zeit nur auf seinen politischen
Vorteil bedacht ist und simple
Schmutzkampagnen veranstaltet
gemeint sind seine politischen Gegner
von der Opposition die Reisen ebenfalls
alle an wie die Chefin der ee-partei
Miral actiona oder wie der Vorsitzende
der größten Oppositionspartei CHP
kemalkilift der wirft der Regierung
Versagen vor und gibt Erdogan eine
Mitschuld an den vielen Toten
es gibt nur einen der für diese
Katastrophe verantwortlich ist und das
ist Erdogan 20 Jahre lang hat er es
versäumt das Land auf Erdbeben
vorzubereiten
Erdbebenforscher sehen das ähnlich
solche Bilder dürfte es nicht geben
während Häuser erdbebensicher gebaut
worden doch es würden Baugenehmigungen
an gefährdeten Orten erteilt meinte
Geologe
und der Grund dafür sei die in der
Türkei ausufernde Korruption die Leute
die das kontrollieren sollen
sind vielleicht auch darin eingewickelt
mit dieser Korruption das ist das
Problem
es gibt keine Kontrolle sehr einfach
ein anderer Grund so schenke sein
Unwissenheit und Arroganz bei
Funktionsträgern und Behörden so hätten
Forscher Kollegen schon vor langer Zeit
eine Gefährdungskarte gezeichnet für die
Stadt Karaman Maras die heute in
Trümmern liegt die haben diese Karte an
Herrn Bürgermeister geschickt
die Bürgermeister hat das angeguckt er
hat gesagt das nicht
und nicht gemacht
woher fand diese man diese Autorität zu
sagen dass er das nicht glaubt
hätte er gehandelt würde es diese Bilder
heute vielleicht nicht geben in einer
Sporthalle in Karaman Maras haben sie
die Toten aufgebaut angehörige sollen
sie identifizieren und können von Ihnen
Abschied nehmen
Yunus und seine Freundin wollten
heiraten Yunus konnte sich und seine
Mutter auf die Straße retten als die
Erde bebte gulchin starb unter den
Trümmern ihres Hauses
am 28 April hätten wir heiraten sollen
für den 28 April war unsere Hochzeit
angesetzt doch es sollte nicht sein
ich wollte sie in einem schönen
Hochzeitskleid sehen doch jetzt wird sie
ein totenkleid tragen wie soll ich es
beschreiben ich fühle mich als hätte mir
jemand Hände und Füße zusammengebunden
so dass ich nicht mehr aufstehen kann
sie betrauern ihre Toten in Karaman
Maras es ist kalt zwischendurch schneit
es immer wieder hunderte sind gekommen
und hunderte liegen wohl immer noch
unter den Trümmern